hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lone
survivor now I apologize sincerely for
the delay in this episode got nothing
special thanks to director
um because I wanted to do longer parts
of this but every time I would get up
and try to record it I go I want to do
really long part of it but I just don't
have enough time and I got really caught
up with other projects I was working on
so I really apologize for the delay I
wanna finish this because I really enjoy
this game I know this game has in
beginning as many views as others but I
mean that doesn't really matter to me I
thoroughly am enjoying this experience
so when we last left off there was just
some big miss ji Lee Jong Lee douchebag
over here who doesn't appear to be
bothered by my oh there's more than one
of them hi hi what are you doing you get
away and I came out of one of the oh
this room here is it gonna okay that's
the insanity room I don't want to go in
there just yet but I don't know what to
do about this oh I don't want to use a
flare but I think I have to they don't
seem to be bothered by much Wow
whoa he just fell down well I guess
that's good but it didn't get the other
guy usually all crap okra ah
Bart's crawling oh that's disturbing
that's slightly how I what what was it
sound was it be all insane how am I
gonna get past those things again
because I don't have any more flares
beef jerky it's not flares I didn't even
come down this way where am i oh I see
oh I'm going the long way around is
somewhere I I don't even know where but
here we go into the darkness gonna be
fine Oh heads pounding why why is head
pounding why is head do that kind of
rice but i mean i mexican turn this off
I don't hear any monsters so I'm gonna
assume that what is that I hear some
hello that doesn't so good okay I'm
gonna assume that that was a big guy
upstairs for now okay this is the other
side of the hole there that sounds
that's got a closed back in the line
okay there's definitely monster monsters
here hey wait a minute it was a monster
monster to the left I don't have any
more flares Oh jump again do those count
is murder because kind of look like a
giant douche to me oh I may have you
know you know what you know I'm I'm
gonna kill I have no other choice right
lamb-lamb
ah back up you [ __ ]
stay away from me come on
oh crap Wow big turn mouth oh whoa no no
no you dad oh I hope that doesn't count
against my score because those guys were
a little more disturbing than the other
ones that I've come across then again
probably not we got here ten of fruit
salad ooh delicious hmm
and oh so nutritious but then again
where the hell am I going this is a long
haul what excuse me Harden
can you repeat that what you say you say
something over there it's over here
whoa what is this distress flare is that
ways that is that the same as flare
flare ah I got flares a little bit too
late but I'll take it you know what I'll
take it beggars can't be choosers and I
I just got something good entrance must
be just up there if we can send the
elevator up there maybe I can trap that
creature in it I don't know uh what wait
what why where did I go oh I was on the
right side oh goody goody gumdrops I
think I need to go take a nap
uh uh after I made it all the way here
I'm pretty sure I do
and hopefully the director have
something for me like more flares I
don't think I picked up any more ammo
either I am low on ammo - all right was
green pill repealed
only got one left took the green pill
tasted funny and it feels sleepy well
let's go to bed I'll have a snooze I
don't know why my head was pounding I
didn't think I got a bleached those and
if they began to then dent again I may
have may Bobbi being in are you the one
helping me
I am what I am and we can only really
help ourselves wouldn't you say is that
something you'd agree with I agree we
can only help ourselves it's kind of sad
that it has to be like that the way the
world is man shame you need this but
here it is you really must eat your
greens I don't have many green pills
left actually I got no green pills left
didn't do much good
what did you give me what did I get I
don't know the director please don't got
nothing special well how about you go if
you're jumping the e I'm still not gonna
try to kill the regular free Community
News but I'm definitely not gonna hold
back on the weird II wonky ones you know
what I'm talking about right
the weird e Wong Keys versus the freaky
DS okay
you're not hungry eat a fruit salad or
something about beef jerky I'm a
favorite salty but solid I get that's
one way to describe it is that is that
what she's dead why did he walk on you
gotta be kidding me oh no what was the
point of coming here oh wait what oh oh
there's something else in this area
there's ad war somewhere over here where
where
I found the handle there we go didn't
even know that was a thing but
apparently it was alright wait a minute
oh how does that help me
ah god damn am I supposed to do I need
to fire the generator up and I was able
to get to the generator but when I was
there I was then able to actually do
anything and I've been to the room with
the question mark why is it still a
question mark though why is that a
question mark in there there's still
something in there that I don't know
there's something in there I got to go
back there's something in here I just
don't know what it is there's something
in here besides the mirror this maybe it
was just maybe this whole room is just
that maybe something to go up there I
don't know none from them I'm mmmmmm not
checked wish yeah all right
I I sincerely don't know what to do
anymore I'm at a complete loss as to
what my real objective is I'm gonna go
down try to see what's going on with the
generator again oh oh it's dark oh
that's better
too dark what are you talking about too
dark which if that was too dark stupid
you're dumb you're dumb with your butt
face oh yeah I forgot I killed all the
ones here
that helps me I guess Wow what the hell
do I do this is where everything went to
[ __ ] but I don't know what they need to
use on it need to use something with it
did you guys tell me because he didn't
see anything then again I can hardly see
it oh yeah did I have that say I have
that did you I have it did I get a fuse
did I get a fuse get a hand
I got a Daiki I don't think I have a
fuse maybe I could use the
can opener I don't have a fuse I filled
it with gas but I don't you oh hang on
let me let me but if I use the cat plush
as a fuels that'll work
ah okay give no kettles just saucepan
pickles wait a minute have I hang on a
second guys I gotta go back and save I
might be on to something that I wow i
hey hey hey don't be like that there was
something that I may have missed I'm in
the translation um before I think when I
saved before I went in a room and I
picked up something that I didn't get
before I had in a previous playthrough
picked up a fuse but I didn't get it
because I didn't go back to where it was
and I was just outside the room but I
had to go to sleep because I was not
doing too well and I needed to get up
again I didn't have any more green pills
to bother with stay with me or saying
but I know what I need to do with just I
hope anyway because I've been wandering
around for quite a while but I have a
good idea what I need to do and where I
need to go I know what I need to do
maybe I didn't pick up fuse before but I
think I distinctly remember something
with Upham was it
I'll show you already yeah get out you
don't have with me don't f with me man
it's from here hello goodbye yeah
there's something in there hang on wait
a minute but how do I get out how do I
get past you how do I uh how do I do
that
I know I don't know I don't know I don't
have enough bullets I could oh I have
one flare left isn't this lovely come
here everybody dance
everybody do the fancy dance I got the
large views which finally means that
I'll be able to turn on the lights in
this son of a [ __ ] ah ha ha so what's
awesome what I don't understand is whoa
whoa you are yeah you're yeah all right
kid but anyway I need to go down into
this corridor put the fuse in the thing
and then hopefully that'll turn on the
elevator and then I go to the other
place that I was just at in order to get
the elevator going up to the thing and
then set it up there and trap him that's
the idea that's the general thing that
we're doing here use it that should get
it going again
Babu's key come on yeah it worked did it
wake then why don't any of the lights
down here wake either way don't matter I
don't care I don't care I got it done
I've killed way too many to get to this
I've actually wasted a bunch of stuff
because I I didn't even need to kill
some of the things to get to where I
needed to go all I needed to do was go
by that way and get that fuse I mean you
guys were probably yelling at me and I
sincerely apologize because you know I
messed up a lot but remember guys I'm
just one man it is hard to play and talk
at the same time so be merciful on me
there it is okay so if I
hmm so I can't move now which means that
something is happening I can't move
oh damn what was that oh no oh no you
might want to run buddy
what if I wanna borrow I need to run
well run then not that way Wow hey I'm
glad I killed these things on the way
out here oh go go go go go go go go go
go this was a bad idea
I can see I'm a [ __ ] I get us oh ah then
I go oh we know which way am I going
where am I going where did I just go
where did I go oh no oh no where am I
I don't even where am i all right
where am i where am i where am i where
am I ow oh I'm about to die I don't even
know where I am I don't know where I am
I can't stop and check my map your son
of a [ __ ] I will I'll do nothing cuz
I'm about to die that's what I'll do
what was it about her now not ever
oh god I'm on a diamond a diamond
in the diamond that I am in the diamond
tonight I'm gonna die and I didn't save
cuz I didn't think I need stay because I
thought this would have worked
I don't know what I'm beyond I don't
know where I'm going where am i where am
i where am i what am i doing what am i
doing what am i doin where we goin I am
going to die well at least I can accept
my fate like a man instead of draw what
now why did he hit me why was that fear
oh wait it wasn't what the hell what is
this bull you tell me to run and you
don't tell me where to go you don't even
give me a chance turn on my light with
that hell that's so stupid now I have to
go back and get the thing again and put
it back in you son of a [ __ ] that was
just unfair that's not a game mechanic
such a chore whatever I'm just upset I'm
upset I'm upset
what opposed I supposed to do I wasn't
able to see where I was going to his
[ __ ] pitch-black
ah this dumb is 10 butts maybe even 11
but that was a loving butts dumb 11
stupid but dumb one I never sent stupid
when I represent dumb
get what
it's good our dance party going and have
a grand old time
well I rage into the end of the days
whatever whatever whatever whatever
don't matter don't matter don't matter
don't matter you don't matter you know
immediately go left cause it can't can't
flip the app and you can see yeah I
don't care what you guys say I'm turning
on the gamma next time I go down that
way next time I go down that way I'm
gonna turn on the game I'm gonna turn it
up crank it up to maximum just so I get
in flippin dip and see and I don't even
know where I wants me to go if I'm just
supposed to run away from it it doesn't
seem quite fair because I wasn't able to
do it I wasn't able to do it Boop yep
okay hey if I know that this isn't gonna
work why am i doing it again
are you guys ready for this gamma going
up it's not much but hey at least I can
see something least I can see a little
bit of something and that's all the
matters it's all they need all right
let's do this yeah buddy yeah buddy once
I do this I'm actually gonna plant in my
oh we wanted me to stay here that's it
I'm gonna do that actually just because
I don't have to do that again travesty
of nature travesty of nature ah I could
cook the rice pudding but I'm not going
to
crunch-crunch-crunch good good good
yum-yum-yum I think what what you just
hate you douche oh I was supposed to
combine this with the cheese Shaw boesky
two and two makes cheese so eat the
cheese and crackers yuk yuk your face
you know what I I spent all day cooking
that and he didn't even come close to
appreciating it I have added up to here
with this guy I have had it didn't do
much good you know what I don't care
I've had your sass can go somewhere else
just can't take your sass and shove it
up your ass eff you in the a and don't
have a nice day it's kind of kind of dev
Yemen care financing alright so if I'm
gonna do this then what's gonna happen
is I'm gonna go left apparently I was
forcing me to go left I just till I go
back upstairs is that what it does or
maybe no there's no way that I could
cause it to fall down into a pit I would
have to go back upstairs it's what I'd
have to do alright here we go Bing bong
oh no how about we go how about we move
how about we move
Oh BAM uh-oh
Oh No now we need to move our ass yep
you need to run bad boy all right now we
just go we go we go we go we go
I can barely see even though the gamma
is literally all the way up but I just
go until I get that and basically I go
left for a long time it's the gist of it
yeah hi buddy hi how's it going you're
really really pretty
missed me you missed me now go in here
and I go down this hallway I'm like oh
no no no why would that stun it like
flip-flop into going Brian why would
that flip-flop ah whatever you know what
whatever okay whatever I don't have any
time to deal with this bowl
thumb thumb thumb thumb thumb thumb
thumb thumb them maybe that was just the
sound of the other monsters actually
running away from this guy because they
don't want to deal with this frankly I
don't want to deal with this but I'm
forced to cuz I'm the only bad and a
badass qualified enough to do this now
after this I need to make sure I go left
because that's the way to the front door
because I'm a big enough douche to take
the long way around
oh you know I take the scenic route when
I'm being chased by a big giant
diabolical monster I don't know don't do
that to me okay good I think it went
away
uh-uh no I need after I come out of this
hallway I'd take a right and then I go
out to here
gasps upstairs not good did I one today
one I think I won yeah but how am I
gonna get past this one do I have any
meat I hope I ever adding meat left oh I
do not know if I have oh good this
police ID right here okay so if I put
yeah wait no can I get right here I just
go in awesome I can but what was the
point of coming in here I don't even
remember I know you're exhausted man
yeah the sleep didn't do you much good
but hey that's the way it goes and the
music has changed I did it I think I
think
I think I think you know what I don't
even know I'm just gonna cook something
real quick and yeah I don't even know
anymore
I don't even know
there we go all right pudding gonna eat
that and then I'm gonna go sleep and
then I'm done with this episode and hot
comfort food at its finest why does he
liked it rice pudding and not the cheese
and crackers what you guys told me to do
that that's supposed to do that it
didn't work okay besides the bowl Hong
Curry of what that was I am still
enjoying this game so I will continue
with this in the next part
hey guys it's me again sorry the episode
didn't actually end I just decided that
I'm gonna play it more because I kind of
want to get through this I wanna I want
to get to something and I don't feel
like I actually got anywhere in the last
part I felt like I was running around
doing a task that should have taken me
ten minutes but instead it took me a lot
longer so I'm just gonna keep going all
right so we need to go through this door
I can't believe I made it at last maybe
it will do me good to be oh I'm going
outside then again maybe it'll kill me I
don't really care to be honest I'm
rotting in there like those things well
it's time to go wait a minute we're just
going outside all unprepared willy-nilly
what couldn't have just gone out my
window you know there's a I know it was
locked and all but fire escape that
would have been a good choice maybe
possibly 33rd Street right then I got
the fire escape oh that's the fire
escape key to my own apartment
well Lodi frickin de ha ha ha with the
whoa
wait are you are you joke are you joking
are you joking me are you joking me
the fire escape was not only right there
to the outside it was only one flip
dipping floor up I could have I could
have dealt
I could've dealt with the idea that you
were high above the ground but the fact
that you are right there right there
right there and somehow magically the
key was obvious
somehow hi that is in forgivable in
forgivable not even Unforgiven
forgivable you have done goofed so hard
that I can't even begin to forgive you
for it
I would have I'm gonna stock up on my
meat I'm gonna make my meat nice and
full and I'm gonna get out of here
then we're gonna go what I don't know is
how those monsters don't detect the meat
inside my pants okay so I don't have a I
don't have a map yet for this area I
just need to go down and well badges I
just found friendly
oh god it's one of those things yeah
yeah I got a guy oh thank you no thank
you no thank you
Oh hidey hole well goody goody it's
actually quite nice out here
oh that's cuz I turned the gam up let me
turn the gamma back on I didn't actually
change my so I'm well I don't want to
deal with you right now but I'll come
back I'll come back I'll come back
someday
oh there's a hidey hole right there how
convenient Oh perfect oh wait not
perfect not perfect these are coming and
no no no no that's right that's right
that's right buddy stay on the other
side of that I'm gonna get the chainsaw
I'm gonna chop you up into good little
bit more chop you up good yeah here we
go
boughs healthy I probably should have
put it more farther over there I would
have been smarter you didn't see nothing
you still human yes
thank god you're alive let me in it's
not safe in here okay one second what
who what where who's there man can you
turn that light off
oh sorry nice one man uh thanks for
saving my neck back there what's your
name I'm Hank
what do you want from me man I'm not in
a good state here well I'm looking for
anyone who's still human hmm yeah well
about that human would barely be a word
I'd used to describe myself at this
point in time one of those sons of
[ __ ] got me you see man I've been
holding out as best I can but I can feel
it starting to take root it started out
as an itch you know one I couldn't quite
scratch you know what I mean
damn I'm sorry to hear that so you're
gonna turn into one of them uh is that
what happens so they say don't really
know to be honest inflation's
informations literally limited on the
subject wow you're really in a bad way
uh will I get it too if I hang around
here maybe I shouldn't even be in here
now with that mask of yours what's with
that anyway huh I don't know really I
doubt that bro
hahaha maybe you're like me under there
that's it isn't it
I don't think so I told you why Hank why
don't you believe me anyway you can see
I'm out of supplies nothing left to give
you about ammo I see you're fond of a
pistol there bro it is good to have
around
well when I'm after his pills man give
me one of the blues and I'll give you a
clip how's that sound
sounds fair to me I think I might have a
source okay I'll see what I can dig up
hang in there Hank just watch out for
those crazies let him get to closing the
end up like me so uh I got plenty of
blues I don't take it myself take the
ammo never could trade these for more
flares eggs are screwed I'll just take
it for them I'll just take it for what
it is and was good enough for me
Bartowski give me the chainsaw out there
I might have a gun old-time all right
Hank starting to burn under my skin I
need to do something I could shoot him
in his face they'd probably end his
suffering can't trade you for some ammo
yeah this is a deal man Lala hold off on
the face shooting just uh for a little
bit shelves are empty even though I had
something on food on him I lost my
appetite a while back dime for grub I
know where to get it though check out
the grocery store on East feet it's the
weirdest thing man someone restocks the
delivery box there every day could even
be one of those things still trying to
go about its old routine
creaky thanks for the tip friend no
problem it's better than eating rat
anyway
yeah reckon it is hi how do I get past
you now look at handguns aren't as cool
as mine
okay you got a Holley hole I'm gonna put
I'm gonna do oh god no time no time
you'll never find me now my style what
do you mean not your style this mean
change star there fine I'll be that way
Oh looky loo it's got tour two things
Schwalm husky haha
sabatello chibi never gonna find me
never gonna give me up
never gonna let me down what the hell
how's that even fair oh that thing is
ravenous well that was disgusting or
what do I do now I'm kind of on boned
you'll never find me
okay yeah yeah you better what up where
isn't the other one doing anything why
is the other one being a son of a [ __ ]
do I got to shoot my way past them
I've been trying to shoot as limited as
possible but am I too far gone
God dingus Kieran zip azam azam ooo be
fine you know what
going down to the club you're going down
in the world
jump
oh god damn it
ah shoot you in the legs in a face in
face in fact I was a terrible idea
how's the worst idea ever whatever I
actually kind of just want to get
through this game just being honest I
want to get I want to get I want to get
through it
I really do lock from the other side let
me guess didn't even need to come this
way why the hell my head don't die on me
now flashlight oh what the hell are you
Oh though what is this light where is it
coming from dude that guy is twitching I
don't like it
wait do I know you I don't know do you
know me
how about now
do you know me now we're on the same
team you and I aren't we so I'm gonna
ask you again do you know me I know you
I know exactly who you are you don't
need to tell me have a seat now let's
what
what tell me right here got me go crazy
I'm not I can't whoa
all righty then
gee are you in this together or are you
making her do this
gee you wake up don't worry about me
I'll be fine you can look after me now
can't you see there's something wrong
with this guy
you know my name why won't you just say
it
Roger glass thorne-smith Billy
wall Thorpe
ha
okay the initials SW are carved into it
no Southwest or what bottle of health
tonic but back
what the hell what I just saw something
you can't tell me I didn't see something
I don't have a map but like oh is that a
map oh well what do you know I just
found a map wha funda BA there's
something marked on the map already it's
near the city limits or least the limits
of the map I guess that's where it
should be heading if you say so man I
need to get back to my hidey hole I'm
doing too good
I seem to be going counter insane crazy
gone not entirely sure I like what I see
well we can't all be as devilishly
handsome as yamimash what what I'm say
they took me up some beans then we get
some hot beans ready for the violet you
lovely I got the warm beans pets pounded
these should fix it I got in a bit of a
scuffle with those guys and hopefully
this will cure it right up
eat it up much better warmed up beans
really are the survival staple of a
future I have a snooze
I needed that I know I did let's see if
the director has anything useful I got
some special enforce in for well okay
nevermind I'm not gonna do that ever
again since I've lamda nuff of these
blue bees I'm gonna just keep up
laminate until it's time to go you know
what it's time to die and honor I'm
gonna stock up on meat and I'm gonna go
on my merry way how about that
wasn't there a box of pills wait a
minute let me what's in there like a box
ah I got pills I knew there were some
pills I knew there was now you can get
more ammo from the duty dotty I didn't
put the bug in here that's right because
I died because this game is a bit of a
son of a [ __ ] but wait what oh no way
I'm opening that one okay so now that I
have that I can take her this guy hello
boo sorry buddy sorry to bother you I
still haven't done with the ham let me
know meet Norma me Steve that guy got
called from like across the map why did
it take so hard good to get through the
other guy the other guys I had to blam
um pull a lad
oh whatever everything's dead here damn
you damn you to hell I'll get around to
one way or another you'll see hey
they'll never find me I'm like a shadow
in the night all right
Bing bong Bing bong ding dong well mr.
director man what do you have for me now
I would like some flares if you got them
so about that stuff I found well here it
is an ESP you have one of these when I
was a kid thanks mr. director I
appreciate all you do for me well I got
no use for them it's just as I said that
may be something you can do for me - oh
what's that then nothing special really
just like I write I like reading the
funny papers they make me laugh one I
love the best is called sleepy cat you
think you can rustle me up oh I have
that I have that actually yeah I have
that I just picked that up like not two
seconds ago I have that I have it is P
there like a gameboy era
bababooey yah ha ha ha thank you kindly
son take this telly
10 a cat food typhoon really give me cat
food cat food you'll all Mona Oh where'd
all my bullets go oh really I'm out down
to 6
oh my down to 6 another gaming items in
10 oh man
fine whatever you know I'm wasting time
anyway I gotta go I gotta get out of
here I gotta get away baby I gotta go
I'm thinking copyrighted songs on
YouTube yeah good idea my life oh hi
why don't you move don't you move your
big nod this way dude
do not make me shoot you I do not want
to shoot you don't make me do it cuz I
will you'll back the F up and tell you
go to hell dammit I'm gonna have to find
whatever you know what
[ __ ] you deserved it you made me do it
how else was I supposed to get around
him I wasn't gonna take the mirror
because oh I could have taken me um
what was that ah you're not gonna talk
about that sound that just slithered it
way the not gonna talk about that not
gonna talk about not gonna talk about
that even little bit oh there was
another door in there hang on this one
can't get it open I think it's jammed
okay nevermind I was wrong so the gold
key that I have had s W on it which
probably means something like Southwest
or Stanley Warbler Salazar whistling you
fat sack of poopy you fat sack of poopy
here I'll give you some that you fir
what what I came up I have cat food I am
good food food I have cat food I am food
I have oh don't run away no now I got
food
what do you mean approach it more
carefully no no no no good man
no my entire psyche run depends on me
finding this kitty no I into cat food
right there I messed it up I'm going to
kill something and it's going to be you
lamb
damn you take a loss of poets Jesus
you're not dead I know you're not ah
hey got you oh that doesn't seem good
that doesn't sound good
that sounds extra double extra bad what
the hell is going on oh oh don't make me
you made me do it you made me do it
oh there was a hiding spot right there
you kidding me
Oh doc dingus you gotta be good you're
kidding me you're kidding me
those guys don't even respond to the
things they're rotting me I don't think
anyway oh man I don't have any more
flares maybe I could slip around him
it's really hard to tell what is hiding
spying what is not move move you big
wibbly-wobbly whoo bleep bastard you get
out of my way
thank you thank you sir thank you ground
espresso pretty what at the car battery
I guess that's gonna be important for
the mystery thing that I don't know what
anything is okay
whatever I've killed my fair share I
haven't murdered fire what I don't hide
there I've murdered far too many to ever
seek Redemption I am a damned soul with
no ammo but I got pills so I can
preferably gets more ammo soon I guess I
think I may be I'm going home I'm going
home I'm going home tell the world I'm
going home
I'm grumbled
I'm very grumbled please this gum YUM
mmm very grumble I didn't pick a green
pail I had him but I didn't do that you
know what fine whatever okay I'm still
enjoying myself so don't worry about me
so I'm gonna trying to finish this up in
one more episode besides this though
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
my pizza delivery is not that important
maybe she is downstairs gosh I hope not
that would be weird
hmm
always her phone okay but this is
playing out I like the first game but
it's so much better they definitely did
fast improvements on houses good yeah
Missy
so yeah stuff